now they're all bowing
now it's unanimous it's the loudest
thing I'd ever heard it was
the best comments of all time simplest
oceans on the show please give it up for
mr. Brian Regan years ago I was a
campaign manager for a dog I'm not lying
I was a campaign manager for a dog I'm
not making this up you guys no remember
Bud Light had
spuds Mackenzie yeah
well I wasn't qualified to be his
campaign manager but I was the campaign
manager for Alex the dog from the
Stroh's beer commercials now Stroh's
beer used to be one of the most popular
beers in the country and that I got
involved the Stroh's ads they would have
Alex would go get beers for his owner
and everybody loved the ads so they
thought let's capitalize on this let's
have him run for president of the United
States so yeah so Alex can't talk
because he's a dog so they thought let's
get like a funny campaign manager and
that's where I failed miserably and what
they would do is they want us to go
around to different cities and we had to
do like six seven eight events a day
with this dog and I had to do this
campaign speech to get this dog elected
I'm not exaggerating when I say that
every single one of these events was
worse than any hell gig I've ever done
before or since
and I had like a a day we would have to
do radio stations we wouldn't bring Alex
cuz he's a dog and can't talk and we
show up and they go where's Alex that
I'm like well I don't know if they told
you but Alex there's a dog he ain't got
no vocal cords or nothin I don't know if
that's true but he can't talk and then I
said I'm Brian I'm his campaign manager
I'm gonna do all the talk and they go uh
like damn we go into the studio and they
would have a microphone on the floor
with a bowl of water and they would say
we were hoping we get him to bark into
the microphone and I'm like I gotta get
a manager something because I'm getting
upstaged by a dog that ain't here we
would have to go to malls supermarkets
uh and I had to like try to get the dog
elected and I would say man he's a great
dog you really look at a man you should
vote for him he's got great ideas and
the handler for the dog would sometimes
just say Alex needs a break and he just
tug on his leash and he just leave for
like 20 minutes to a half an hour I
needed a guy with a leash
talking on me Brian needs a break I was
getting no breaks
so I would I would tell The Strokes
people what do you want me to do while
Alex is gone and they would say we'll
just do the campaign speech anyway and
I'm like there's no dog here they say do
it anyway so as people are walking by I
go man he's a fantastic dog you really
got to hear his ideas people are looking
going what is this guy talking about
there's no dog somebody should get a
straitjacket for this guy I was horrible
everything I was having nightmares at
night I was literally having nightmares
I would wake up in the middle of the
night look and then I didn't know what
whether was better to go back to sleep
or to stay awake because both of them
were hell on earth it ended up we're in
Minneapolis this is true I get in the
car in the morning and they said all
right here's the deal by Brian you're
going to bomb in the morning on the
radio and then you're going to bomb at
the supermarket then you're going to
bomb on local TV then you're going to
bomb at a pub and then tonight we're
going to an NHL hockey game it's between
the Minnesota North Stars against the
Chicago Blackhawks and I said great so
when we're done we get to like enjoy a
hockey game they said we're not going to
be done you're going to go on center ice
between second and third period and
you're going to do the campaign speech
to get this dog elected now at this
point we are in the car going about 60
miles an hour if I'd been smart I would
open the door
and just taking my chances with the
roadside gravel we get to the hockey
arena that night my heart is pounding
I'm from Miami Florida I've never been
to a hockey match I've never seen ice I
don't want to do this I don't want
anything to do with this during second
period there's a fight an NHL fight
gloves off blood teeth all over the
place and I'm thinking wow this is cool
I've never seen a hockey fight and then
I went wait I have to follow a hockey
fight
buzzer ended Stroh's people came up said
we're gonna do some little different
Brian what we're gonna do is we're going
to put Alex on the Zamboni and we're
going to drive him around and just let
him circle around the arena on the
Zamboni I said fantastic so you don't
need me they said oh no you're still
going out there to centre ice to do the
campaign speech but we thought it would
be nice if alex is circling you on the
Zamboni I'm like can't you think of any
more obstacles why don't we get an NHL
guy to fire some slap shots a pee
so they get on the voice of God ladies
and gentlemen please welcome from the
Stroh's beer commercials Alex the dog
and the Zamboni comes out alex is like
confused
you sit next to the driver the crowd is
going berserk they just saw a hockey
fight now they're seeing a dog and a
Zamboni they're plenty entertained they
don't need to see what is about to
happen and now please welcome the
campaign manager Brian Reardon they
don't explain that I'm his campaign
manager
they don't say he's running for
president there's no context whatsoever
just please welcome the campaign manager
Brian Regan so I walk out I'd never been
on ice so I don't want to go fast I'm
just walking slow to 12,000 people gone
who the hell is this guy I slowly walk
out to center ice and I'm thinking Who
am I Who am I what am I and I'm looking
around I'm seeing just Alex going by on
the Zamboni and I keep turning the
opposite direction and I just keep
seeing them and I'm like what happened
to me in my life that I'm here now what
choices have I made to be here now
12,000 completely confused people I'm
not smart enough to reset and go hey
didn't tell you alex is running for
president I don't say nothing I just go
hey how about that election huh
12,000 huh what's this guy talking about
and I said you know a lot of people
think this election is going to the dogs
we might as well vote for somebody who's
qualified people start booing I start
hearing this low boo boo and I'm like
what the hell is going on and I just
keep turning around and everywhere I
look I just see round lips hmm I see
Alex going by booth so I figure well
maybe I'll get him with the next joke
Bush and Dukakis to caucus that sounds
like something Malik's might do in a
bush now they're all booing now it's
unanimous
it's the loudest thing I'd ever heard it
was louder than any jet engine it was
and I just I thought well it's not smart
to face the booze I'll turn around like
over here it's going to be people
throwing roses over here boo everywhere
round lips kids boo little old ladies
boo the samboni driver was booing Alex
was booing her so I'm thinking this
ain't doing nobody no good I said well
you guys have been great
I'm going to get out of here I just
wanted to come out have a good time with
you so good I with all the circling I
couldn't remember what direction I had
come from so I'm just walking going I
don't think this is the right way and I
see this guy with a security Vasko and
so I have to turn and from the fight
that were blood and teeth all over I had
to move her I didn't want to go fast
because I didn't want this to be the end
and I look at the exit and it's this
little square rectangle and it looks
like it's a million miles away and the
closer I get the smaller the rectangle
gets it's like mathematically impossible
so I realized with the boos I didn't
even need to walk boo all I had to do
was stop and the force of the boos was
push it was like a boo
sailboat I just put my arms out and it
literally pushed me through the little
hole and the next day Stroh's filed for
bankruptcy
you guys are great man thank you